you
time to go fishing if you don't know
what I'm talking about I'm referring to
the H pond okay here we go ferris double
the cube let's try it over here what's
that the anti fishing pole the Dutch the
Dutch what is dad oh oh get my night
here let's go I could have taken it but
I want to get here with the fork
everybody loves a fork and just trade a
bunch and at the end I get a rook oh I'm
getting material gone is the rook
resigned back to tournament - oh alright
let's get rolling here fishing pole from
the black side decline it if well it's
that Queen up - what is she up to
oh I can't I couldn't take it it was
pinned tricky stuff on my rook the ante
castle go here on that pond I'm that
bishop I like him better take that
bishop I should taking the pawn rook
here where's she going
big trouble I'm not even sure what that
moves doing let's come over here I can
move that rook with some attack now this
is gonna be dangerous right I'm hitting
the knight threaten you to take he's a
free night some checks are we got here
Knight takes no I'm on this pond right
now it's my bishop doing nothing he's
looking to do some pin though Queen
takes Knight Queen takes pawn I could've
taken the night but
let's do this the rooks pinned I'm not
gonna he resigned back to tournament not
taking those pin pieces never unless I'm
forced to a fishing pole from the white
side keying in on age seven another
building a center I got it I got a
strikeout I can't let those pawns rule
the earth here I can't let them push me
over here so let's get castled that was
almost a mouse slip so are they gonna
just give it back
whoa hang on here hang on a little scary
I don't like these uh these holes over
near my king but that came at a cost
yes it did why am I not moving along it
took that night is so dangerous he
really really is I need to get rid of
him
they takes here okay I'm on the Queen
just want to challenge that rook think
what's that doing I'm on the queen that
was check I'm on the rook I'm gonna take
the more active one I'm on the bishop as
well there I'm getting the other one no
matter what may resign they're not
resigning need to pre move everything I
don't want any time to come off my clock
time burner mode anything
let's do anything I don't want any time
to come off my clock no time down on
time they're in check right now with
rooks e6 back to term at their downtime
12 and then six is all right it's uh
let's let's keep going with that I think
I think the plans gonna be keep going
with the fishing pole until it it's
successful in age two and then mix it up
with a different opening let's just
reinforce that you take with your beep
on towards the center I'll do the same
not too much has changed as a result
yeah let's get my night developed
control e5 maybe look to jump into d4 so
I'm setting it up nigth 3 it's h5 I'll
still do this so that diagonals weakened
it's an open file let's get there I
could have taken that Bishop on takes
that I'll do that I'm looking to
sacrifice here I really want to do that
now it's defended let's let's do this
Knight takes pawn Knight takes pawn I
have this square covered let's try this
I was gonna do if Knight takes pawn
Knight takes pawn here and then take on
h4 I'm hitting the knight right now I
could take here next and I'm threatening
Knight f6 it's just a free pawn though
maybe I should have taken a knight first
now I'll do this well take here I don't
have time Knight here check no matter
what unless Knight takes pawn take that
where is the mate rook here can't be bad
i takes here seem to defend everything
though this is trouble for white they're
in big trouble now okay this is big
trouble Bishop takes pawn next exploit
the pin unless that move is played I'm
just gonna give the Queen back I don't
want this stuff over here just get rid
of that tricky Knight anything my
goodness why am I not moving
any move oh my goodness that's close to
me somehow King is getting too close to
it to my king I wasn't gonna be mate but
it scared me here's this is a guy that
scares me
John Madden John Madden I'm gonna set up
the fishing pole against him he knows
it's coming but it's why not he's trying
to set up the fishing pole and so am i
oh that's great that is great we're both
trying to fishing pole one another
who's gonna be successful okay let's see
how dropping my c4 pine oh my goodness
this is gonna be weak Oh watch out for
h2 oh my goodness
I have everything covered though I'm on
the rook watch out I'm on the rook right
they might resign no Queen trade I'm
gonna get another Queen soon right this
ponds really fast you can't be stopped
canny
you can't be stopped that Kings not
gonna stop him is he oh my goodness that
was almost the adobe flash game at the
little screen came up okay he's still
trying to converge on each to maybe I'm
on the bishop and the pond they resigned
back determent they missed that rook
right that pond move discovered attack
against the rook we were both trying to
fishing-pole another man we played go
fish in that one I was go fish
all right okay I'm up a pond here we
were playing chess we're playing go fish
okay up upon a pond here creepy sex
I don't know why I think that's so funny
it's not funny at all
oh man it's just been too long it's been
too long
that's the problem okay let's just
finish development how about that
it's just finished development there's a
lack of development here for team white
and I don't even know what what's what
that moves doing oh my goodness I almost
dropped h7 there had to have been a
better way I want to get on this light
square diagonal could I do that and then
made on G 2 or H 1 take the pawn yeah
that's smart move Oh 17 seconds is not a
lot it should take um Winfrey exchanges
my goodness oh that's a free queen they
were pre moving that was not a good
premium no no it's kitchen-sink
variation right pile up pile up time
looking to capture here made here next
that's Gigi all right back to tournament
42 42 40 okay 20 ah this isn't a good
start to uh if I want to try and get the
fishing pole is this guy not gonna move
while he is moving let's get this in I
have a space advantage to keep this dog
and I'll open for my Queen still have a
space advantage still set this up here
I got to overprotect this pawn I think
yeah what was that sound okay I didn't
want a castle because I still have
thoughts
I still have thoughts of fishing pole
but that's out the window I'm dropping a
pond now after the Queen trade take on
d5 yep so though they're getting that
pond they're not taking it though so if
they're not careful I'm gonna get a big
center big center on its way tsunami of
ponds potentially to back up I still
want to defend this pawn pawn push
steamroller be 45 let's take your first
Castle Knight here back up I like my
LightSquared bishop I like both my
bishops they're both doing a good job
well not just yet this is a good
diagonal pointing right at f7 the knight
moves I get to the seventh rank I mean I
could do a better job pawn push soon
let's just double and I need a flight
square as well hanging out of that
Bishop 10 seconds bishop here I guess
I'm gonna do that they're not moving
okay doesn't matter at this point
any move back to turn with are down on
time 56 54 42 a lot of 42 is I think 2
or 3 all right hey I didn't even get a
quick win I need a quick win and many
players I don't think I don't think I've
played many of these players before
actually I love that dark square bishop
it's Ryan okay I want to put my dark
square bishop to use attack their King
Knight here might be an idea this kind
of scares me Knight e4 into here kick
that guy around a little bit keep oh I'm
dropping this
um what am i doing I just want to open
stuff up over here against the king it's
opened get to this square with check
it's a nice move and then here get the
rook and then pawn push oh just take
that oh come on I wasn't going fast
enough there I want to trade I'm on the
rook and then this square this is
trouble I was close to mate
open stuff up very quick 19 seconds
where's the mate
that's my dark square bishop doing he is
pathetic that's me back to tournament 72
70 56 56 those pigs watch out for those
pigs
oh I'm winded winded I'm out of shape
with when it comes to these tournaments
okay let's go again this is uh just
played this guy not too long ago right
all right and I wasn't able to get the
fishing pole in still maybe get it silly
in a castle I push here there's a castle
already right everybody fearing the
fishing pole going the other way could
try to go in that direction too maybe
that's just sack Knight takes I'm taking
it he's gone he's got to go now I'm
gonna Castle and throw my rook on the B
file I describe protected by my knight
oh not anymore
[Laughter]
whoa come on let's go here I gotta get
rid of this [ __ ] up without he's the
glue
he's the Elmer's glue of this King side
position here oh my goodness would you
slow down look at how many pieces are
over here my knight he's getting
hammered oh my goodness I need to trade
I think it's too scary
oh my goodness this bad this is so bad
night here is gonna kill me oh what's so
dead I need to hang on to my tricky
night though I need to hang on to my
tricky night even a tricky night could
make some time burning moves here that's
what I need
get out of any checks I want to avoid
trades that's the plan avoid trades oh I
want to take that bishop get rid of this
Knight and look for some mate over here
they don't have any time actually not
even gonna come down to material no
gasps laughs no time back to tournament
9072 I was busted in that one ejected
Lee gone out of here okay stay focused
now
stay focused look at this the
creepy-crawler variation isn't that
actually an opening all right I like
staying on this diagonal it's weakened
because of f3 he's gone far enough I
don't want to do its face gaining those
although I gave up this square
let's throw my pawn down I'm looking at
each two still looking at h2 still
looking at each two somehow right
somehow somehow age - okay pawn push
it's made on each - they're gonna do it
not quite they're gonna take the pawn no
take here I'm gonna swing over Oh
smashing through on that square now h2
coming up it's happening made on h2 oh
my goodness why does that move played
made on f2 f2 f2 take it
9090 look at this 1990 86 70 70 68 13
were beyond the halfway point oh no no
no no no no I had I didn't refresh I
have 110 I slide
I still have an edge Queens gambit
declined change variation I played this
recently against the computer impossible
opponent it's flying it's flying I wish
you would slow down so I have some time
to breathe move space gainers space
invaders space invader over here on
Queen the Queen side b5 trade rooks
force them into taking me bishop c7
chops the Queen unless that move is
played okay I want to get into C 6 C 6 T
quit the pun he's passed and I could
support him what's that night up to get
out of here you're up to no good he
really is he's in my territory and I
don't like it oh my goodness
watch out for e3 push the pond to
Victory Lane
I can't move my knight I'm gonna get
hammered over here I think maybe not
kick their night around Oh what was I
just saying oh they didn't do it
let's take here and then here look at my
time I'm gonna get checked like crazy no
they're not doing that I probably had
something better and take my knight No
okay here's the plan
advance okay get my pawn Oh time burners
that was a sneaky time burner that's
made packed turn yeah 131 1088 oh this
guy again I said the one who thwarted my
attack he had me beat objectively but he
ran out of gas
no time left nobody is castling kingside
okay let's try to get it let's go here
Knight g4 enabled Knight g4 here we go
remove the defender next take the knight
h2 is right around the corner you have
to play g3 I'm pretty sure this is what
I like Carlson try it against gates okay
take him take him I'm on the bishop in
h2 again watch out oh that wasn't on
just yet I'm on the bishop in h2 again
it's easy to miss f4 maybe is the only
defense that's not really working I'm on
h2 on the bishop again I got to watch
out for f7 halves I'm gonna meet me I
could take the bishop and run though my
king is fast h2 really isn't working
I'm gonna take here and then run the d8
just in the nick of time he's out of
there just in the nick of time that's
throwing this check prepare to run fast
okay the rooks in a pin that can't be
too comfortable I want to get my bishop
out one day there's no time they're down
to 11 seconds b6 let's keep things
closed pond takes I take the knight and
I just want to complete my development
less than five seconds b6 Bishop d7
or or b5 they have no time back
determine who 151 3106 less than 10
minutes away if we get paired up that's
gonna be a big game he's giving me a
beating last time I think I don't know
how many played but I think the last
time I got a beating and a half okay
here we go
will he knows all about the fishing pole
this name is familiar to me it's still
kind of scared I know it's not really
gonna happen now when you go with the
kingside fiend kettle that's it's a way
to a good way to defend against it
okay now Space Invader right here space
gainer and let's take here and tempo
yeah let's get my queen working it's
probably not good
eventually temple gaining move on f5 I'm
opposite their queen if we take a bunch
of times at the end of it I have a
better structure should I think at the
end of it no matter how you look at it I
have a better structure I like my dark
square bishop I'd save him
pawn push here I'm just doing this to
soften up the kingside position at H
pawn and let's let's let's break it open
here break it open again and jump my
knight in there which it takes I take
with the bishop pointing at the King if
the knight moves I could take here and
let's let's go for it
I want to take on this square with check
it's working and it's and that's not me
yet though
whew why is it taking me so long to make
a move Oh got to do this is that working
Queen takes your queen takes bishop it's
very scary
I don't really like this position I feel
like I'm missing something um I just
gotta make a move any move am I missing
something please no please say it's not
gonna be the case here 9 seconds is not
a lot look at the pins look at the pins
we're even on time I'm gonna throw in
time burners now I think what they
disconnect they're not moving they must
have disconnected no I didn't anything I
just need time burners down on time back
to German 180 not first must have had
two quick wins I gotta catch that guy
now Roger Rogers here there was almost a
bad joke that came from I'm not there
right who knows
Roger
I mean I just can't say it just can't
say it all right so let's see v6 get my
bishop opposite their Bishop beautiful
commentary I'm gonna get my bishop
opposite their Bishop oh really is that
what you're gonna do okay if I do this
Knight b5 is annoying let's go here so
maybe I defend this first and then play
here looking for some sacrifices on h2
and then I'm gonna watch over this
where's my king I mean I know where he
is but is he safe they're going i'm
castled now I'm on there rook after the
capture I'm on there bishop I missed
that retreat back here or do I just grab
the the pawn on H till I'd really feel
more comfortable just retreating they're
gonna resign clock tick they resigned
back determine where are we at 190 mm I
have a leave now but they're probably
ready to win five minutes 42 seconds if
we get paired up that's gonna be the
decider the designer that will those
points I need a quick kill back to
tournament they they don't want to play
oh we're level we might be paired up
right now 15 games apiece here it is
here it is oh I'm still gonna try
fishing Paul
oh that's the anti-phishing Paul let's
be aggressive let's be aggressive maybe
get these moves in Queen d7 oh they're
gonna play that sneaky sneaky look at
this guy flying he is flying
was my night even doing Oh where's my
night belong not not where he's out
there he's bad he's bad news there
night's gonna be strong here I could
take him out though I don't even know
what that moves doing that's the point
isn't it I'm gonna take that oh my
trouble maybe watch out for my back rank
I have a covered my bishops there oh I
don't really want to do that or that
what about this I'm a material so I
should be welcome to trades right I'm
gonna trade times about even oh I didn't
want to go there it's okay
King here King position um are the
checks time burners I want to trade
Queens
can we just trade Queens pawn push I
didn't want to do that
it's a savable you have a check and go
here 13 seconds I grabbed a pond that
Bishop is just so good light square
control oh oh oh no oh no oh my goodness
adobe flash gambit No Oh what was that
oh-oh-oh-oh the adobe flash game it
didn't come up on the screen
ah I think it's how untimely ah that
killed me I mean keep in mind I still
could've lost even if that didn't happen
but that didn't help didn't help my
clock's ticking it's my move oh and even
realized it was my move just then I'm
still complaining about the previous
game oh now this dragons gonna kill me
oh man dropping a bun oh boy oh boy they
still have a minute a minute I have the
Greek gift why are you not Greek gifting
this guy here get over here right here
is where you belong look here mate 1 2 3
4
rook here let's mate soon
same story mating - if the rook moves
now I get on g7 mating - they're gonna
let the clock tick two-minute warning
what do that ah they're gonna let the
clock tick dragon dogs don't do that me
too
just move any move oh man clock ticking
oh here we go back to tournament 218 I
still have a chance to 22-18 ah they're
ready to probably win can I get a win
here oh wait a second this I might get a
boost here somehow right if it doesn't
pair up there's an error I get some
points and then and then the next game
oh my goodness did you see that I'm
trying I'm looking over the chat I have
a second to look in the chat was it
coming up on the stream that Adobe Flash
game at that stupid thing here we go oh
I have to play there's not that air and
then give me point stuff haha
so this was this is nothing now there's
no chance I gotta go for sneaky stuff
I'm still gonna go there I'm still gonna
go there it's happening no matter what I
just have to go for cheap tricks
that's my only hope I'm going all-in
I had to shut down that idea actually at
the end of it oh well I got to reinforce
my Center 40 seconds it's not happening
I need a win
soon late d7 he's gonna go for a night
hike they might make us finish this game
if it matters if it could change the
result of the the final that's beautiful
right let's stay opposite that rook
that's exactly where your game wants to
be when he dreams he dreams about being
opposite rooks f6 that'll stop him
that'll stop him right in his tracks
what about Knight f4 that's a beautiful
squared get there it's this rook doing
nothing what's my bishop doing he's
staring at a rock stared this Knight
oh I missed that it's very dangerous
very oh there's a beautiful fork now I
get the Queen they get my queen back I
get the rook that's it they called they
blew the whistle on this tournament
second place confetti oh man oh that was
such a tight game - without Adobe Flash
damn it got me good
even if I won that game that wasn't and
just wasn't gonna happen all right
good games oh all right
you